hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play amnesia
the Dark Descent a custom story by the
name of Castle of devastating diseases
now it's been a long time since I played
amnesia and when I fired up the game in
the intro music played I got this chill
run up my spine and I'm really excited
to be back you know I was waiting for
Ebony's UI machine for pigs frictional
game what's up you know want to tell me
but I don't know where that's going so I
was gonna hold off until that came out
because I thought it was coming out like
last month but apparently not so I'm
here with a really highly rated custom
story since year of 1352 there's been
hasn't been devastating diseases now it
is 1852 and there's another devastating
disease going on you are the most known
doctor of the century and you have
received an invite to try to get
patients healthy in that small northern
European Scandinavian town plague signs
plague patients was gathered in a huge
castle which was better known as a
hospital 500 years ago when the Black
Death was storming you have invented new
medicine medicine called calamine
calamine lotion and now you are going to
try if it helps with disease I said got
to play in the headphones with dark rum
check there we go I'm ready I'm so ready
I'm ready to be scared by amnesia this
is a very highly rated one by the way it
has like a 9.3 I believe which is very
rare to find these days with amnesia got
some stories so oh man it's been months
since I played this so oh hello hi can I
go back out can I run away
I should really try to help these basins
not run screw you okay alright
apparently I cannot run away fine
whatever I'll stay there seems to be a
puddle of water and water dripping from
the ceiling hi Alexander this is a
really old castle no joke
you know hospitals back in the day they
weren't really a place for oh no oh I
already had the lantern with me no I
don't I do not oh there's a lantern okay
got it got it got it
Oh tinderbox how I have missed you
the darkness I can't wait for a machine
for pigs hi you bastard
I can't wait it's gonna be so amazing
but you know some people forget that
amnesia is like the perfect horror game
it's so set up to have custom stories
ready cuz the environment I'm cranking
up the music the volume even louder I
mean just the natural um just the
natural ambiance of the game it's just
fantastic
it's just meant to be and it's allows
creators to just make cool stuff and
when a machine for pigs comes out
they're gonna have so many new toys to
play with a kid wait I'm so excited I'm
a little hyper this morning because I'm
finally mic off has finally gone like
I'm seriously is the first day I've felt
100% healthy and I woke up and I was
like oh clear lungs nothing bad hello
how you doing sir sir you are sick you
need a knife to the chest
you you want some light sorry I don't
have enough tinderboxes to go around
let's see take this here and then oh
you've got this weird case of breathing
I need to fix that up right away he's
not breathing anymore and all right
these patients are now cured I'm a
greatest doctor ever okay nice tattoos
don't like those Oh skull really wait I
got a fun game to play look at your
friend Johnny hahaha I'll set him right
here on your face so that you don't miss
him in the night okay hello hello
Matthew in Section 1 where you are right
now there are only patients who have had
the plague just up to a few days in
Section 2 & 3 those patients have had
the plague for a longer time in these
sections of pipe in connection to the
machine room and machine room you can
set your medicine to ventilation valve
and then set ventilation to active hope
that will help with these patients
patients are held in shackles because
played side effects is aggressiveness
dr. Antonio okay whatever you say dr.
douche I'm the only doctor who's worthy
of any reputation I don't even know what
I'm talking about what is this oh well
just put that on your butt put that on
your face and you'll be better in no
time so just take care you're gonna be
great I put him out of his misery he was
suffering you didn't see anything
don't question me job nurse I'm a doctor
of course I know what's best so there
seems to be some things inside the walls
okay that was weird I don't recall that
sound never being in amnesia then again
you know if you hunt around I've hunted
around in the ambience files in the
sound files of amnesia there are some
weird unused sounds in there and it's
very strange okay section two it's
locked but I'm a doctor you're supposed
to let me do everything I want fine
whatever
whose shackle in their chains oh quit
moaning we all got problems all right
let me cure this patient - yeah right in
the neck okay he's good all right
another patient saved for another day
hello hello oh quit moaning ma'am we're
all hurting oh you knocked over my
bottles of wine well aren't you just a
son of a [ __ ] I'm just gonna stuff a
funnel into your face and then funnel
wine in until you die so just hold on to
that hold on to that and I'll be back in
a bit okay wait am I supposed to do
something here huh looks like I might
need to come back to actually squish
some stuff together
oh come on well where am I supposed to
go and let me just double-check to see
if I didn't miss anything here uh it
doesn't look like it let's see okay
we're good all right so I need to go
back and do something I have no idea
hello where do you go ah the machine
room I can set my medicine to
ventilation 8-valve thing no magic er
whatever you know what I mean
oh man more people moaning in here oh
don't think no god I don't want to hear
them moaning all day okay where's my
nurse why isn't my nurse Lee helping me
out here hello hello hi where am I going
wait a minute this is mm nope how about
down set calamine the ventilation valve
I don't know what that means
but I'm just gonna take your word for it
okay get that that are they about to
turn the lights out on me is that why
they're feeding me tinderboxes where's
this ventilation belt oh here wait what
Dwight oh here we go
I have that with me all right let's do
this her bra engine now working get the
engine working where's the engine love
the ambience it really has been quite a
while since I've played amnesia so I am
very much happy to see all of this going
on
okay so engine not working some problem
over here
okay must be on the other side of the
room over here I mean with all the time
they're taking for a machine for pigs
I'm hoping that it's gonna be something
fantastic I don't know if I need this
piece of coal but I'm guessing I do oh
wait here we go aha I knew it ha ha ha
that's why I haven't played this before
it's just that my amnesia instincts are
just so good how about now cut not
enough coal need more coal all right is
this the coal room yep here we go
gimme I don't need this lantern I'm just
wasting oil probably three pieces if my
instincts are telling me correctly yep
give me thank you and in there there's
enough coal Bob ow that must off [ __ ]
you then all right there we go engine
works now good for me now I go turn on
the thingy and then I'll go along
'we good all right let's get that
calamine pumping because everyone knows
calamine is just as good as penicillin
or every uh any other sort of antibiotic
just as good
I think calamine isn't it used for anti
itch is medicine is now on the way to
the patient's you may know if it's if
it's gonna be a good thing why did that
Ottoman this music start playing what
I'm sorry did I cause some prop
okay that's not good that's not good
okay some sort of red viscous goop has
gooped itself all over the walls so I
can't get out that way what do i do then
hi by going into the cellar cuz that's a
good idea
alright yo the scary things are gonna
happen soon I shouldn't be this happy
but I am I'm really happy to be back in
there me Jie I mean you know I played it
like just a ton last year and then I
kind of fade it out really quickly so
whenever I come across a good custom
story it always just tickles me and
makes me happy hello hello I mean the
grammar on this one is kind of off but
you know some of these games are made by
people not native to the English
language so gotta give it a chance even
though I can mug hi how's that column on
doing for you you don't look so good man
you didn't I look good in your very
naked my name is dr. morgan i was the
most known scientist in the world this
century that's me Oh 13:51 nevermind I
tried to invent new medicine now plague
patients I thought I had invented it but
it didn't go as I thought I gave
medicine to patient but their condition
didn't raise on the contrary went down
and with those who had already their
condition very low they got some kind of
mutation they didn't look as human
anymore and they became very aggressive
I think nobody knows about those things
because one wasn't allowed to get in
this castle without a specific reason
now I hope nobody tries to cure plague
patient with that medicine called
calamine it caused this all but why
would the same medicine because that 500
years apart I don't make that Oh
I'm sorry I won't question your logic
game what where what
ha na diet huh take it a box Wow okay
that's not good not good
I know good okay I'm gonna be in here
you don't do [ __ ] okay okay alright
alright these lights go out oh why are
they still red hello hi how you doing
there
you're doing good you're doing good
you're doing good buddy doing good buddy
hi it's been a while hi didn't hear
anything buddy you didn't hear anything
you didn't hear Zuzu's huzzah huzzah I'm
just gonna hi by this dead guy don't
mind me
no don't come in here that's right you
heard something no now what why and then
that long since I played yeah that's
right
turn around you're just mistaken no no
what is that what is that bull okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna run him to loop-de-loop
got ugly
come on loop de loop loop de loop loop
de loop loop de loop de loop de loop
loop de loop you douche loopy loopy
loopy loop de loop there we go ah okay
miss me alrighty then
get away I'm too good for you take a box
so the first yeah now take a barrel ton
of ice
alright we're on our way we're gonna win
we're gonna be great we're gonna do it
do it do it do it
look me a push yeah that's what I'm
talking about
got it lock it up sweet Oh dead end
well that was a mistake is he still out
there where did he go away I don't see
him I'm gonna assume that he's gone
which is probably a bad assumption to
make okay all right he seems to have
disappeared which means that I can move
on unhindered oh it's been a while since
I met my friend mr. faces megaminx
cousin I like that name the best mr.
face
this place looks eerily familiar that
skipper that's from the original amnesia
let this play out it looks so familiar
you didn't see anything didn't see
anything buddy the monster just came out
of a bad idea that's a bad idea
oh I thought my cough was gone
it wasn't until I start inhaling vast
amounts of spit all right no hiding I
don't have time to hide it even though
he's right outside come on come on no
don't no no no no what are you doing
yeah that's right yeah that's right move
on buddy
you don't belong here this an alien
monster alien monster who don't belong
is he going if he's going the other way
I can sneak by okay good I just need to
get to that door and I should be fine
cuz he's making a loop-de-loop oh yes oh
come fast
okay there's another door right there w
no don't look at him
you don't hear a thing buddy
you do not hear a thing close it very
gently very very gently okay whatever
it's okay got a lever what is this
oh the lever that's right there was a
lever there was a lever to that thingy
okay where is he meep
don't come anybody don't come in
everybody I gotta get around you oh are
you going to run the other way good good
that's what I thought and now I'm going
to run fine why are you there you were
supposed to be around the corner
what the hell what l buddy yeah come on
girl come on oh and I jump over your
head
super Parker Parker Peter Parker oh hey
it's gotta close behind isn't he he's
kind of like really close behind isn't
he oh good he got stopped up by that
door okay so then I just latched this
onto the thing in there and then I slam
the handle down what was that
why are those the thing get I don't care
whatever get open I said get open there
we go
all right yeah all right yeah suck on
that monster so I got my door oh what's
that
what yeah that's not the same monster
that's a moose man alright terrific ah
you can't get to me anyway okay so
that'll do it for the first part hope
you're enjoying this one this is gonna
be a pretty good custom story I can
already tell I'm um so excited to be
playing them knees again so and you guys
could stop reminding me about that it's
the East at Eagle statue
so anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the M Jason more videos
that I've done and as always I will see
in the next video but I sent people down
as always it's prior to friggin Canada
I know that you know that go buy it
again first
[Music]
Oh God
[Applause]
now me Sammy okay I'm an idiot why did
that scare me I have no idea